では よろしくお願いします
今日は法句経の勉強でございます
何番でしたでしょうか
25です  法句経の25番目です
ウッターネナッパマデーナサンニャメーナダメーナチャ
ディーパングカイラッtemeダーリーヤンオーゴナビキラーティ
という経です ウッターネナッパマデーナサンニャメーナダメーナという人間が育てるべき一つ性格的なことをね
説かれているんです ウッターナということは奮い立つという風に訳していますけどね
で 一応そういうアッパマーダっていうのは不放逸ですね
怠けないことですね サンニャメーナっていうのは落ち着いていることですね
ダメーナっていうのは自分を制御していることなんです
そういうことで自分をしっかりしてくださいと
例えば話がございまして
島を造ってくださいと
どういう島かというと
どんな洪水にも あの 何て言いますか
え こちら流せないという
いわゆるあの水が出てきて
島が沈んでしまうかもしれません
いわゆるどういう風な洪水が出ても沈まない自分を造ってくださいと
こちらで言うのは まず一般論で言うならば
どういう逆風があっても揺らぎない人格を作らなくちゃいけない
自分を作らなくちゃいけない
しっかりした自分を作りましょうと
で それだけだったら まあそうでしょという気持ちにはなります
その方がありがたいのではないかと
しかし どうやってということが出てくるんですね
だからお釈迦様はもう完全に語りますから
このどうやってという疑問は成り立たないんです
そちら全部方法を書いてるんです
ウッターナ 奮い立つこと
アッパマーダ 不放逸ということですね
怠けないで努力すること
サンニャメーナ 落ち着いていること
ダマ 自分を制御している
そうやって自分がある人格を育てるんです
それでどんな洪水にも沈没しない島になります
自分の人格は それからこの言葉一つ一つの意味を説明してみます
ウッターナっていうのはどういうことかと
それがこの立ち上がることなんです
まあ腰を上げることなんです
そういうのは別にあまり意味
そんな意味がわからないかもしれません
しかし これは心の法則を見て教えられていることなんです
心っていうのは常にこの怠け
怠け癖がついているんです
何もやりたくないっていうのは心の本性なんです
ダラダラしたいというのは
で これが自覚しておかないといい人間にはなりません
決して我々は自分をペンキ塗って心にね
ああ 格好いいやと 綺麗やと思ってはいけないんです
人間っていうのはいつでも自分の人格にペンキ塗る作業をやってるんです
で 中はサビだらけで で
ペンキ塗れば塗るほどサビが増えていって
もう元の状態がわからなくなって崩れてしまうんですね
で そういうことだから
世の中で人気ある話をする人々は
人気者っていうもの 人がたった一つの手段を使うんですよ
どういう手段かというと
相手を褒め称える 相手を褒め称えることで誰でも人気者になります
できるだけもう上げてもう上げておくんです
乗せられちゃうんです
これ いとも簡単にその餌は釣ってしまう
もう食べてしまいますよ
だからどんな人でも釣り上げられたくなったら
褒め称えることですよ
で そこで何が見えるかというと
私たちは自分が立派ですごく完璧で綺麗だとと思っている
それで誰かがそれはその通りですよと言うと
大変気分がいいんです
自分が隠したがることをバレてないんだと
あ よかったと こう気分がいいんです
普通 日常生活の中でも
私たちは何か隠し事をしようとする
で 隠し事を誰かに隠しますから
その人には見事にバレてない場合はすごく気分がいいんです
そこで調べれば調べるほどバレてないということは
自分には確かめることができればものすごく安心するんです
ですから どんな人間でも褒め称えると
気分が良くて その人のファンになってしまいますね
で その言った人を言うことは何でもやるということに
結局はすり上げられること状態になります
このマインドコントロールする場合でも
同じ手法を使っているんですね
それで見事に人をマインドコントロールする
で 仏教の違うところは
このあんまり褒め称えるということはしないんですね
で 事実を生々しく言う
それがお釈迦様が自分の憐れみの心で言っていることで
人を騙してはいけないんだと
[咳]人っていうのは苦しんでるんだと
自分でも自分を騙してるんだと
そんなもんではどんどん不幸になるだけであって
いいことっていうのは一つもないんだと
そういうわけで 人を騙すことをしないで
人の心にある悪いところは全部バラしちゃって
あんたはそういう思うほど立派な人間ではありませんと
本当はこういう風な人間だよと全部バラしてあげて
そこを解決する方法を教えてあげるんです
ペンキ塗るんじゃなくて
汚れの上で汚れをきれいに落としてピカピカ状態に持ちなさいよと
そうするとペンキ塗る必要はないんだと
そうするとペンキ塗らない方がいいんです
自然のままで美しく輝くんですね
そういう方程式が裏にあるんです
それで我々人間だけではなくて
どんな生命の心も 本来はまあ怠け癖が過ぎてあって
まあダラダラしたいんですよ
いいことに何かやらなくちゃいけないことはやりたくはないんです
やってはいけないことだったら
いとも簡単にやってしまうんです
それが確認しないと その特色を
この本性を確認しない限りはいい人間にはなりません
で 暗示かけても 私はいい人間だ
いい人間だ 頑張る人だと暗示かけても
ああいうものはインチキ的な方法で正しい方法ではないんです
で どうせ暗示かける人の人がまあ糸を握っているんだから
その人の心の それで独立した完璧な心になったわけじゃないんです
ですから 暗示かけるんじゃなくて
仏教の方法っていうのは暗示を解く
それで不安になるかもしれません
でもそれはしょうがない
そういうことですから
私たちどんな人でも結局は怠け者である
いいことだったら腰を上げたくないんだと
悪いことだったらもう自分で進んでやってしまう
そういうことで自分の心に聞くんですよ
自分がどんな心を持ってますかと
自分の心に聞くと 自分がもう美味しいものをいっぱい食べて
よく寝て ダラダラ生活したいという気持ちがあるんです
子供の例で言えば 勉強することは嫌で
遊ぶことだったらものすごく好きで
いつでも遊ぶという だから
自分にとっては悪いことだったら喜んでやる
自分にとっていいことだったら
あんまりやりたくはない
で 子供の性格を見ると
正直だからすぐ見えるんですね
それは 大人になっても同じ性格なんですけど
大人はかなりそれをごまかして嘘をつくんです
だから子供と大人の違いところはそれだけ
子供は嘘をつかないし
大人は嘘をつく 大人も自分にとって悪いことだったら進んでやりたいんです
自分にとっていいことだったら
まあどうしてもやる気にはならないんですね
しかし それは言わない
認めない それで一向に成功しない
成長しないんです だから事実ですよ
子供は成長するのに 嫌々なんですけど
それでも早く勉強して大人になるのに
大人になった時点でもう何の進化もないんです
退化はいくらでもあるんだけど
進化はないんですね そういうことで
そういう状況をまず理解する
理解したところでどうすればいいかと
そこで必要な仕事があるんです
ウッターナということ
今まで説明したのはそれなんです
やっぱり腰を上げたくない気持ちがあるんです
だったらしょうがない
とりあえず腰を上げる
とりあえずやってみる
いわゆるスタートするんですよ
うまくいくかいかないか
そういうのはどうでもいいんです
大人っていうのは こんなこと難しくてうまくいくわけないんだよとやろうともしないで言っちゃうんですよ
これだったらもう人間失格なんですね
まあ結果どうであろうともいいんだから
まずスタートする だからこの 第１歩
それを進んでください
それはものすごい簡単ですよ
だから怠け心にそれわからないだけ
どんな大胆なことでも
第１のステップは別にどうったことはない
この世の中でやらなくちゃいけないということは
もういくらでもありますね
これはやるできるわけないということでも
ものでもいくらでもあります
だからできるかできないか
どうでもいいことで まず一番最初にどうするべきかということ
それだけやってみる その性格をついてほしいんです
例えば富士山を平らにしようと思っちゃうと
いきなり頭に出てくることはできないという話でしょ
できないんだと まあできるかできないか置いといて
では平らにしてみればどうですかね
それだったら最初にどうすればいいんですかね
一番最初にやらなくちゃいけないことはできるはずなんです
そこらなるくわでを持って行っても掘っちゃえばいいんだから
それができないわけないでしょうに
だから将来の結果妄想するんじゃない
それはなんで将来のことを考えるかというと
もっともっとやりたくないんだからなんです
だから あまり将来について計画立てる人がもう決まって普通の人よりも怠け者なんです
計画立てて立てて立てて
将来の夢を作る作るという人は
決して人生は成功しないんです
ただ目の前にあることを淡々とやる人が何一つ失敗しないんです
失敗しないということは成功するということなんです
だから 富士山の例えでも考えてください
富士山を平らにすること
できるかできない そんなのは将来のことでわかったもんじゃないんです
とにかく自分が決めたんだから
もう 第１のステップは取るんだと
くわでも持って掘ってみると
それで物事は動くんですね
だからそれが性格的なことで
まあとりあえず最初のところでもやってみると
それやらなきゃ影響的にはやれることはできないんですよ
それでこの最初のステップを踏むための性格を育てなくちゃいけない
では次の問題は？では最初にじゃあ本書こうと思って
まあ機械のスイッチ入れた
それ最後の最初のステップだからね
まあそれで書けるかというと
まあそれで書けるわけじゃないんです
スイッチを入れて まあそれで終わっちゃう
で いつでもこの気分 気持ちをね
腰を上げて最初のステップをする
一つのステップ終わったら
では次のステップやりますと
と 目の前にあるあの単純なステップだけ踏めばいいんです
文章を書こうと思ってスイッチ入れただけで
すぐ文章を全体的に考えちゃうと
もうできないんです 全くできなくなるんです
だから 決して将来のことは予測するんじゃないんです
予測した途端 もう怠け癖が出てきて
できるわけないんだと
難しいと 疲れたと 明日やるんだということになっちゃうんです
ですから 常に我々はこのウッターナという性格をずっと育てなくちゃいけないんです
自分自身を変えなくちゃいけないんです
ウッターナがある人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
奮い立つことある人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
それ決して難しいことじゃないんですよ
ずいぶん単純で ステップは三つ
四つ 五つの先を考える必要ないんです
はい これはやりました
次に あ 次にこれ それもやった
では次になんですかと
ずっとそのやる気ということですね
俗世間の言葉で言えば
やる気ということは決して失ってはいけないんです
次の問題はやる気がある人もいますけど
すぐなくなっちゃうんですね
やる気がなくなったと
それなくすための次の言葉アッパマーデ
アッパマーデということがあれば
もうやる気が だしたやる気が続くんですね
アッパマーデの意味っていうのはもう大変難しいんですけど
その場でその場であの解釈はもう変えてするしかないんですけどね
なんで人のやる気がなくなるんですかね
何かやりますとやる気満々になっても
なんか知らないうちにやる気がまるっきりなくなっている
それは別な情報心に入るんだからなんです
気が別なところに行っちゃうんです
例えば 人が何か文章を書いている
それに誰かが来て ああ
これがあまり良くないねとかね
なんか言っちゃうと すぐ自分の気がその人言ったことに行ってしまうんです
それでできなくなるんです
あるいは自分の文章をチェックする人がいるとします
その人はそこら辺に来る来ただけで
もう手も足も動かなくなっちゃう
で 心に別な情報が入ってしまったんです
心が汚れてしまったんです
自分の仕事から脱線したんです
だからやる気が失うのはその時なんです
よくチェックしてください
自分たちの人生を やる気があるんですけど
すぐなくなる なくなったし
なんでなくなったんですかと調べてみれば
頭に別なことが入っているんです
で 心の法則を知っている人は
まあそんなもんでは何もできないと知っています
心っていうのは一つしか仕事しないんですよ
たくさん仕事を同時にするということはできない
心一つしかないんだから
一つの仕事しかしないんです
それはよくこういう日常生活を観察するとよくわかることなんです
何か手紙でも何か書いていると
頭が別なものに行っちゃうと
もう手が止まる 全部あれできなくなる
その性格を直すのはアッパマーデなんです
いわゆるこのやってることに集中する
それ別に大変な集中力は要りませんよ
ほんのちょっとしかやりませんだからね
で 富士山をもう平らにしてやろうと思ったっても
実際にやるのはほんのちょっとの仕事だから
それに集中することできないわけないでしょうに
実際に自分がクワ一つ持っていって
それで振るだけのことだから
それに集中しなんでできないんですかね
だからクワでちゃんと土を取って別なところに捨てると
それだけやればいいんです
で 誰が来てあんたこのバカなことをやめなさいよと言った途端
頭がそちらに行くでしょう
できなくなっちゃうんです
やる気がなくなっちゃうんです
だからこの その どんなことでも
自分がそのやるその仕事に集中しないとうまくいかない
失敗する 例えばガスコンロに火を付けるとする
それすごいつまらない仕事でしょうに
しかし それをやる時でも
ちゃんとそのマニュアル
あれ何て言いますか ありますから
それを見てそのやり方でやれば一回で火がつくんですよ
それで機械の疲労も少ないし
自分に時間も儲かるんです
誰かと喋りながらスイッチ入れて
また入れて また入れて
回入れてからもう火を付けるんだから
機械はそれその分は無駄に仕事をしている
自分の時間なくなっている
そういうふうに微妙に我々は時間無駄にして
それを計算してみるとすごい量なんですよ
無駄にする時間の量は
だから そういうふうにしっかりする人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
電気のスイッチ入れようとしても
そこを見ないで他のことを見ながら
こうやって手を当て探ってスイッチ入れようと思うとすごい時間かかるんですよ
本人がつの仕事を同時にやってるつもりですけど
それはできない できればすごい微妙に物事を見る人間になってみて
スイッチを入れるんだったら一回で入れる方法を探す
だったら集中しなくちゃいけない
スイッチがこちらにあって
こういうふうに入れますと
その時手に本があったかもしれませんよ
その瞬間で読む必要はないんです
それも私たちにはない性格で育てなくてはいけないんです
この瞬間に 気づいておく
それが集中力っていうことなんです
1時間集中力とか 30分集中
そんなバカな話はいいんです
だからやりたくない人々は集中力
それは素晴らしいことですけど
自分にはなかなかないんだよと
なんでないんですかと
大変難しいだよとか そういう人々は
この 1時間の集中力  1 日間の集中力
それ考えてるんですね
ありえない話 だから富士山を平らにしようと思ったら
その怠け者の人が考えるのは 1発で取って捨てるっていう方法なんです
そんな方法ありませんだからね
物事は瞬間で動くんだから
瞬間瞬間で動くものだからね
そういうのはないんですよ
だから集中力得られる方法って言えば
何かもうそうやって大胆なスケールで考える
で 何もやらないことになる
だからお釈迦様推薦するのは
この瞬間のことに集中してくださいと
それはアップマーダっていうことなんです
混乱しないでいること
だいたい怠けないというふうに言いますけど
もう怠けないという意味よりも
混乱しない状態 では 次の言葉ではアップマーダっていうのは
なんで仏教ではキーワードになってますかというと
それが大変大事なことで
真理発見するために 悟りを開くためにはアッパーワールドが必要なんだ
アッパーまでだけですべて発見できます
アッパーまでだから 瞬間のことに気づくことなんです
それで一切の物事は瞬間でしか成り立たないということがわかるんです
それで自我もなくなっちゃって
自我という妄想概念もなくなって
悟り開けるんですよ だからすべての真理を発見するためには
たった一言アッパーワールドですよ
時間の軸で長い軸 長い時間間隔で取っちゃうと
そういう人には永久的に真理がわからなくなるんです
物事っていうのは 怒りの速度ぐらい速さで変化していくんです
その瞬間に集中すればいいんです
この瞬間でこういうことになったと
それで無常というお釈迦様の真理を発見できるんです
だから仏教においては大変な
大きな 偉大なる言葉なんです
ですから この集中しましょうということで
集中しましょうと言ったっても
この大胆なスケールで集中というわけじゃないんです
ガスコンロに火をつけるんだったら
その瞬間にそのスイッチに集中する
その上にやかんを置くんだったら
その瞬間に集中する こう置きますと
それだけで人生はうまくいくんですよ
それだけのことだから
次に別なことに集中すればいいんだから
はい 次の言葉に行きます
サンニャメーナという言葉
サンニャメーナっていうのは落ち着いていることなんですね
冷静にいること これ冷静に落ち着いていると言っても
まだまだ具体的じゃないんだからね
具体的なこと こういうこと
我々はなんで落ち着きがなくなるんですかね
なんで落ち着きがなくなってイライラ状態になるんですかね
で それは考えたことないかもしれませんだけど
ただ自分が落ち着きがないんだよというだけで
何とかしてくださいと
何にもできんだからね
落ち着きがないのは自分だから
これ自分で落ち着くしか方法ないんですけど
やっぱりなんででしょうかと調べないと
なんで落ち着きがなくなってるんでしょうかと
これはこういう方法なんですよ
方法ではなくてこういうことなんです
我々の目に耳にいろんな情報が入るんですよ
目の耳にも鼻にも口にも体にもいろいろ情報触れるんですよ
情報触れるたびに混乱する
何か見たらもうすぐ混乱する
何か聞いたらそれすぐ混乱する
それで落ち着きがなくなるんです
では 何か見たら混乱した人はそれ見ているんですか？と
見てないんです 初めから
見てないんだから 聞いてないんだから混乱するんです
よく聞かれる話で瞑想しなさいと言ったら
もうかなりこの周りがうるさくてできなかったと
時計の音がうるさかったと
ということは そういう人は音は聞いてないんです
時計の音で 音で聞けば混乱しません
聞きたくないぞと思っちゃうと心が混乱する
聞きたくないんだったら聞かないのは正しいんだけど
しかし聞いて聞こうとする
聞きたくないと思う それで混乱する
見たくないんだったら見なきゃいいでしょうに
しかし 見る それで混乱する
何か仕事をしていると
誰かが横から何か言う
仕事中だから もう本当は気分的には聞きたくはない
しかし 中途半端で聞こうとする
これで混乱しちゃうんです
聞きたくなければ聞かない方がよろしいし
聞くんだったらやってる仕事やめてそれを聞けばいいんです
そうすると混乱しないんです
だからこの情報入るとすぐ混乱する人が何一つも結局はわからないでしょうでは皆様よく知ってるでしょうに
落ち着きがない人が何一つもロクにしないでしょう
落ち着きがない人は何一つもロクに勉強しないでしょう
でも勉強しよう 仕事をしようとはする
するんだけど 結果がゼロ
何もうまくいってないんです
ということはやってないんですよ
だからやってないんだったら
私はやってないんだそうと言えばいいのに
それもできないんですね
そのもうだらしないやり方はやめない限りは心は落ち着いてもらわないんです
だから 聞くならばちゃんと聞く
聞かないんだったら綺麗に
それはもう自分の脳細胞からもう捨てる
カットして 見るならばちゃんと見る
ちゃんと見ると何のこともないんです
ちゃんと聞くと別にこういうことですというふうな知識が入るだけであって
混乱はしない そのそのものについて認識が生まれる
それだけで混乱はしません
だからしっかりした認識が生まれないんだから混乱する
それでどうすればいいかというと
まあ何か見ると混乱するなと思ったら
もう堂々と見るか 全く見ないことにするか
ヴィパッサナー瞑想では
そこはもう直すために
ちゃんと確認して見なさいと
これでサンニャーマという性格が身につくんです
音が入って混乱しそうになるということは
自分で聞いてはいけない
でも聞いている聞いてはいけない
でも聞いているという感じになるんだからね
他のことをやらなくちゃいけないんだとかね
それでヴィパッサナー瞑想でいうことは
やっぱり音が入ったら音
音とそれは確認して置いておく
そうすると たとえこちらで救急車が行っても
消防車が行っても混乱することはないんです
人と喋っている場合は
もう消防車が走るとすごい音だからもう喋れないんです
その時ものすごいバカデカで喋っちゃうと
もう結局は混乱するだけで喋ることやめて
その音をじっと聞いてみれば
全然何のこともないんだ
落ち着いてるんです それ終わったらまた話は始まることできます
だから 入る情報その瞬間でちゃんと確認するっていう作業で
その性格はなくなります
で 私も混乱することがありまして
で 嫌になるほど瞑想のやり方を教えてますけど
ほとんど聞いてる人っていうのはいないんですね
もう何年もやって あの
まあ集中力ができませんでしたと集中することを言うんです
で なんでそう言うんですか？と
ちゃんと膨らみ縮みを見ることはできませんでしたと
私はこの人は初めからあの
何年も付き合っているんですけど
一度も話聞いたことないんだと
その瞬間であんた帰りなさいという気持ちになるんです
それで何百年やったっても同じことだから
話聞いてないんだから
だから言ってるのはその時その都度その都度の情報確認しなさいってことなんですね
その話聞いてないでしょ
それで音が入っちゃうと
あ これは聞いてはいけません
聞いてはいけません 膨らみ縮みやらなくちゃ
そんなことで混乱しているんです
聞いてはいけません いけません
だが聞いてるんですね
それ人格はできない 聞きませんと思っちゃえば聞かないんですけどね
人格ができてる人は ああまあ音入っても聞かないぞと
よくできますけど 普通の人間には耳があるんだから音が早くぶつかるでしょうね
で 聞いちゃうんですよ
だったら確認するしか方法ないんです
それをやらない その代わり無茶苦茶混乱する
それで自分が瞑想しているつもりでもいる
してないんですね するんだったら 1時間
2時間でもほとんど進みますからね
だからこの混乱する状況っていうのは
そういうところであの
実際に修行なんかする時はよく分かりますけど
日常生活の中で我々は同じことをやっていて
混乱状態でいます いわゆる情報に我々は左右されているんです
自分というものって何もない
音が入ると音のまんまで動かせるんですよ
何か目に見えるもの入っちゃうと
そちらから私を管理するんですよ
情けない生き方なんです
外の世界が私を管理している
自分が何者ですかね 何の存在価値もないんですね
だからこの仕事をしたりすると
すごく難しいや混乱するんだ
落ち着きがないんだ もう困ったんだと言ってるでしょうね
それはもう存在感がないんですよ
生きてないんです ただのもうなんでしょうかね
外の情報に左右されてしまう
だから 周りの世界にはやりたい放題できます
自分の心管理 それがないようにするんですよ
サンニマっていうのはそういうことなんです
人が怒ってキャーキャーキャーキャーといろんなことを言うかもしれません
しかし なんでそれによって自分が怒るんですかね
言わせちゃえばいいでしょうに
自分が聞かなきゃいいでしょうに
聞かなくたって どうしても耳に入るんだったら
それは音ですと 今この音を聞いてるんだとハッキリと確認すればものはすみますよ
自分がその人の話を聞いたことにもなってるし
話聞いたんだから相手も落ち着くし
自分も全然怒ってはないんです
人が怒ってキャーキャーと文句言うと
その人の狙いはこちらに嫌な思いをさせようという狙いでしょうに
で 向こうは勝ってるんです
自分が生き物じゃないんだから
存在価値はないんだから
もうやりたい放題やられっぱなしで
それで本当に相手のことを聞けばいいんです
ここ混乱するものがあれば
それはちゃんと見ればいいんです
ちゃんと自分の意思で見る
自分の 自分が主人で 自分がマスターで
自分で見るということをしなくちゃいけない
自分で聞くっていうことをことをしなくちゃいけない
聞いてしまった状態は良くないんです
聞かれてしまった 見えてしまった状態は良くないんです
見えてしまったら 聞かれてしまったら
もう相手側のやりたい放題のことになってしまうんです
自分で聞けば 自分で考えれば
この新興宗教とか そういう人をもう浸透させようと思って
向こうはペラペラペラペラ喋る
簡単に乗せてしまうんです
それで判断能力も何もなくなっちゃって
愛する人形になってしまうんです
人が喋るのは自由ですよ
同時に自分にも聞く自由が
なんでそれ使わないんですかね
では聞くぞと 聞いてみると
自分が主人公主人で 自分で聞いてみると
相手の感情に左右されることはないんです
で 落ち着くという状態は
そういう風な ちょっと難しいことかもしれませんだけど
そういう風に育てるものなんです
難しいとは言えないんですけどね
あまりにも感情的で 世間の情報に左右される状態はなくした方がいいんです
それでサンニャーっていうのは
とにかく心混乱しないようにして
自分が自分の 主導権かな
自分が自分でその主導権を取って
見たり聞いたり考えたりする
それで混乱しないようにする
それで落ち着きます 落ち着くための方法はそれだけなんです
主導権は自分で握る 普段
世の中では誰にもそれ使ってないんですよ
誰も 自分の主導権ということは
言われるまんまで こうしなさい
ああしなさいと 言われる通りにやるだけで
コマーシャルみたいな世界ですね
コマーシャルでもよく見ると別に買わなくてもいいということがその中に入ってるんです
ただ嘘言ってるだけなんです
なんとかなんとかの映像を組み合わせて
全然関係ないもの 美しい自然を出して
タバコの箱の写真があったり
何の関係ですかね 一番綺麗に作るのはタバコのコマーシャルですからね
私も全部見ます 結構綺麗だから
南アメリカの砂漠の方でやるそうなんですか
そこら辺の写真貼って
マールボロというタバコの宣伝がありまして
で ラークという場合はね
また有名な俳優さん使ったりとかね
あれとこれ関係ないんだから
見れますよ 綺麗だなとかね
それで全然それでもってマールボロ買わなくちゃいけないというメッセージはないんです
でもあんなインチキに騙されますからね
ファッション関係の雑誌だ
買ったことはないんですけど
宣伝しか見たことはないんですけど
あの 今年の今月のなんとかファッションなんとか
髪はこういう風なことで
もう今度は茶色でジャケットですよとかね
で 今度の秋のズボンのなんとかとかね
ばっかりあるんですけど
であれ見たら ああまあこの出してる女
女にはこのズボンが合ってるんだよと
それだけ あ こんなポーズ取ってるんだから
こういう風に綺麗に まあ綺麗ですよ
格好いい  こういう風に格好よく見せるために結構苦労したんでしょうとかも思います
だからってみんなあんなものを着たっても
もう猿みたいで全然かっこ悪いと思いますけど
でもみんな着る だから美しくなるはずの社会が
ただの 日光の猿軍団の芝居みたいなもんなんです
あの猿たちも服を着ていますけどね
別にあれですごいかっこいいってことはないんだからね
猿は裸ですごいかっこいいんですけど
服を着せちゃうと気持ち悪いって
犬にも服を着させてるでしょうに
毛が足すほど気持ち悪いんです
同じこと人間もやってる
で たまに私もやっぱり調べようではないかと
誰が服を上手に着ているんでしょうか？という
100人見ても見つからないんです
2  3ヶ月間ぐらいあちこちで行ったりすると
たまに一人ぐらい それ覚えてないんですよ
もう見たらもう覚えておくんだからね
でもみんなそれなりに高価な服やらいろんなものを着てはいるんですけど
合わない合わないって
あれはあの雑誌に もう何と言いますか
もう管理されている情報に本人が生きてないんです
ただの操り人形 それで苦しいでしょうね
人生は お金いくらあっても足らないでしょう
それで混乱しっぱなしで
何かものを買っても次のもうまた別なもの出ているんだから
それで買ったものについても納得いかなくなっちゃうし
それで精神っていうのはガタガタで
人格はまるっきり成長しない
猿のまんまで終わってしまう
例えば私がもう遊びにやっていること
誰もやってもないでしょうに
いろんな人を見ると この人とこの服装合ってるかないかとかね
で 最近思い出したことなんですけど
まあ日本でもあちこち体に穴つけることを始めたんですね
で まあ自分の国でもインドでも女性はやっぱり耳二つに穴開けますけどね
まあそれには慣れてますけど
そちらもずっと伝統的にやっているんだから
格好悪くはないんです
まあインドでは南方とかね
すごいかっこ悪い たくさんつけた方がいいっていう風に思っているんですけど
南インドではね それはあんまり北方はそうではないんですね
やっぱり耳二つに合うような
あの なんとピアスをつけておく
タブですか 耳たぶに合うような
あの だから顔も顔だから
それに合わせて まあデザインで何かつけておく
それは先生ももう慣れてるんだから
目はね 日本でも初めて
そこまで私はあまり違和感は感じなかったんですね
耳たぶに穴を 女の人も穴を開け始めたんだよと
もう慣れてるんだから
これから男たちもやりだしちゃって
で まあ男は子供だからね
いろいろふざけたことをやってもいいんだけど
やっぱり穴開けるぐらい穴が残るんだからとかね
おじさんになったら穴があるとね
あんまりちょっと良くないんだから
そこら辺を気をつけた方がいいんじゃないかなという気持ちもありましたけど
まあそれまた慣れちゃったんですね
先生 全然違和感今は感じません
でもこの間見た男の人はこちら穴三つ開けて
こちらも三つ開けて全く別な金属をつけてるんですね
合わない やりすぎ それは男でしたけど
まああの男の顔と体の形から見ると
まあまあですね 一つぐらいはいいかもしれませんね
三つはちょっとやりすぎやと
これで止まらないでしょ
今の女の人というのはこの真ん中にこちらの唇のそちらも穴開ける
鼻に穴開ける 舌にも開ける
どこまで開けるんですかと
だからただ開けただけでいいわけじゃないんですよ
みんなやってるんだからということじゃよくないんですね
それはもう操られてるだけで
だから自分の主導権を持って自分がやるかやらないかというふうな考え方が必要なんで
でないと混乱ばっかしの人生になるんです
だからいろんなコマーシャル見てみると
やっぱりなるほど 買う必要ないんだという私にとってはそのメッセージなんです
だから何という すごい下手なのは車の宣伝なんです
買う必要ないというメッセージがずっとあるんです
向こうは一生懸命考えて作ってますよ
でもあんな能力だからね
みんな操る人間だからできるわけないんです
それに騙される人間も騙される側もいいことで
でも車のコマーシャルもそれなりにすごく綺麗にできてます
だから綺麗な作品としては見えますけど
でもせっかく向こうは高いお金払ってね
車を人に買わせるために作ってるんだから
そのメッセージは入らないんですね
ただ組み合わせればいい
どうせみんなバカだから
それでもう騙されるだろうという感じで作ったりする
だから私は言いたいのは
この情報に左右されることでは
されるならば もう一向に心は混乱したままで治らないんです
だから見ては悪くないんです
見たいものは見なさい
聞きたいものは聞きなさい
食べたいものは食べてみなさいという態度なんですけど
でも主導権は自分で 自分で取る
でないと頭が良くならないし
落ち着きもなくなっちゃう
では 次の問題は この自分が主導権を持って見たりしたっても混乱する可能性あります
その時の混乱は質が違う
何か自分で見た 気に入った
あ 欲しいな欲しいなと思っちゃう
それが欲しいという一貫した感情だから
落ち着きないという状態でもないんです
あるいは他の何か見た
すごく気に入らなかった
ああ 嫌だという気持ちが生まれてくる
なんであんなのはあんまり面白くないとかね
汚いとか醜いとかね それで嫌な感じが生まれる
それで一貫して嫌な気持ちあるんであって
別に混乱してるわけじゃないんです
あんなのは見たくはない
もう本当に嫌ですよというふうになってるだけで
しかし これで困りますよ
見たものは綺麗だったら欲しい欲しいと思っちゃうと
見たものは嫌なものだったら嫌だ嫌だ
もう見たくはないとか
そうやって怒りを作ったりしちゃうと
ろくに人間にはならなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまた自分の主導権が主導権がなくなっちゃうんです
また自分を怒りか欲が支配しようとする
そこで番目のステージにその人は進まなくちゃいけないんです
見たいものは見なさいと言うんだけど
もう一つありますと それは何なのかというと
自分で見る場合は自分の主導権を取っている
しかし 見たものを見たところですっごくそれを欲しくなってしまっちゃうと
また主導権がすっと滑ってしまうんです
またなくなっちゃう その時はさらに自分を管理する
怒りやら欲やら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
そういう感情に自分を支配されないようにと
それは次の言葉 ダメなという言葉なんです
例えば何か見たら綺麗だ
いいなと 別にということで終わらないと
私にもそういうものあって悪くはないんだけど
別に要りませんと なくてもいいと
という風に自分で自分の感情を見事に管理する
その中でも欲と怒り 無知
嫉妬 憎しみという感情は決して立派な人間を作らないんですね
人間をダメにする ですから
その感情はやっぱり管理するんじゃなくて
生まれないようにした方がいいんです
怒り憎しみが出そうになると
いえ そんなの心が汚れるわ
自分が情けない人間になるんだから怒りませんと
嫉妬はしませんと みっともないんだと
あんなのを欲しくて欲しくて堪らないなんて動物みたいだからみっともないんだと
そんなに思わないんだよと
デパートを歩き回ったっても
いろんなもう人の心をもう騙そうと
いろんなものありますよ
騙そうとして でもまあ綺麗のは綺麗ですけど
まあだから何という感じでいけばいいんです
何か面白いことも なんか面白いものあるんだぞと
それを見て理解して帰ればいいんです
だから私は皆様誰一人に質問したりしないんだからね
説法する協力はゼロだから説法成り立ちません
質問がない場合は仏説は
でも情報がないと喋れませんだからね
私はデパートやらどこで見ても全部見ます
関係あろうがなかろうが
もう何でも全部見ます
見ても別に買うつもりはまるっきりないし
買ったって私には関係ないんだからね
で まあそれで物事を観察するのはいいことで
観察すると自分には知識情報が入りますし
しかしそれでもってあれが欲しいとかこれも欲しいとかいう風に感情が現れると
また同じ問題でまた主導権が滑ってしまっちゃって
もう奴隷になっちゃうんですね
だから気をつけるんです
例えば私は女性のところに行ったっても
そんな感情は生まれませんだけど
電気関係やらパソコン関係のところに行ったら
これがいいなということは現れるでしょうね
そこら辺で気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
いいと言ったっても 品物
私は品物はいい でもやっぱり大したことはないと
だから全部調べてはいるんだけど
では実際に買うことになっちゃうと
それでまた困るんですよ
まあいろいろあるんだけど
全部ろくでもないものだから
やっぱり気に入らんと
だから観察しているんだから
そういう風になっているんですけど
ただ感情で言っちゃうと
これが欲しいということになっちゃうんです
欲しいと思ったか買ったところで
必要な能力がその機械にないかもしれません
私の方程式は必要な能力よりはいくらか能力がついてるものを買うと
そうすると後で悩むことになりませんと
それはその能力は一向には使わないという
まあそれで 2番目  2番目
次の言葉 サンニャという言葉
サンニャ という言葉は
この感情を生まれないようにする
感情といえば欲 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみなんですよ そういうものが現れちゃうと
自分がもう犬猫になったと
猿になったと え？あ ダメーナ
ダメーナですね すいません
間違った ダメーナという言葉ですね
犬猫みたいになったと
もう情けなくなるんだという風に思って
観察はして 感情は作らないようにする
で では欲を作らなきゃ何を作ってはいいんですかね
欲と怒りでなきゃ 面白さ作ってください
あ これも面白いと これもバカバカらしくて面白いと
この品物作った人はなかなかいいこと考えてるんですよ
面白いと 欲しいってじゃないんです
面白いということは興味であって
知恵につながるんですよ
面白いという気持ちは楽しいでしょうし
で それは面白いだけで
自分と特別に関係ないんですよ
いろんな食べ物 でも大変豪華ないろんなものはある
なかなか面白い食べ物やと
おそらく美味しいでしょう
でも私はダイエット中だから関係ない
そう思わなきゃ やっぱりみんな苦労してるでしょ
だからずっといっぱい食べて痩せるダイエットやらいろんなものを売ってるんですね
あれ全部体に毒で むちゃくちゃ毒食べてるんですね
最近あるのはこの貼っただけで痩せる
それで食欲がなくなるんだと
もし そうじゃないと思いますよ
ただのもう何か貼るだけのことだと思いますけどね
もし体に貼っただけで脳に影響を与えて脳管理されて食欲は変えるんだったらとても危険なものですよ
遊びじゃないんです だったらきちんとしたプロの医師
医師が 脳のね プロの医師が決めてくれないと
そんなのは店そこら中に売ってるはずがないんですよ
そんな脳に直接影響与えるものっていうのは
これ麻薬系だから だからあんなものは完璧なインチキと私は勝手に
使ってないんだからわかりませんですけど
だと思いますけど みんな買うでしょうね
いっぱい食べても もうこれ貼るだけで痩せますよと
今使うと痩せる石鹸といって
あ そうですか  ソニーのソニービルの中
あれは何かハーブの匂いが入ってて
それの匂いを嗅ぐと食欲が抑えられる
それであんまり太らないダイエット効果がある
それ結構売れてるんです
売れてるでしょうね でも匂いの関係で食欲をなくなるんだったら
もう吐き気が出るほどの臭い匂いでないとね
そこら辺わかってないでしょ
気分いい気分になる匂いっていうのは
結局は脳を刺激するんだから
もう食欲だけじゃなくて他のところまで刺激するんですよ
全部脳はお互いにネットワーク作ってるんだから
そうはならないと思いますけど
でも線香の匂いとか嗅いだら食欲はあんまり出ませんけど
いい匂いっていうのは
そういう働きはあるんじゃないですか
選んでくれたり 食欲があんまり起きない匂いを選んで作ってみたいです
実際はどうですか？ まあそれもね
すごい個人差があるでしょうね
私にとっては食べ物の匂い嗅ぐともう食べる気はまるっきりなくなるんです
それだから個人差があると思います
匂い嗅ぐと中身すぐわかるんです
匂いで ああ 食えたもんじゃない
これも食うかと という気持ちになるんです
匂いで内容わからない人にはこれできないとかと思います
私は匂いで分かります
塩は足りますか？足りてないかってぐらいまで
塩には匂いないでしょ
匂いで言えます 自分が自分の食い物作るんだったらね
味見はしません まあ人に食べてもらいますから
見る必要ないんですけど
で 匂いで あ これで塩十分だと
自分で食べる場合はあまり塩好きじゃないんだから
それでまた匂いで管理する
入れるか入れないかということも
で まあそういうことで
それだから匂いについてはかなり個人差があるとは思います
まあとにかく我々はこの自分にとって関係あるかないかということをわかればね
そんな体に悪いものをね
もうつけたりしたりする必要ないんですよ
どうしてもあの油系の食べ物を見ると食べたくてたまらんという人にとってはそれは苦しいし
だからこれは私の好物でいいんですけど
私には今関係ないんだと
そういうふうに黙ということをしなくちゃいけないんです
だから面白さだけあれば
これがすごく美味しいですよと
これはこういうふうに開けなきゃダメですよとかね
例えば油系の揚げ物好きな人だったら
これはこういうふうに揚げた方がこれ揚げ物はあのお店は一番美味しいんだよとかペラペラ喋ってもいいんですよ
それは自分の知識だから
しかししかし 私には関係ないんです
これはもうダイエット中だから
減量中だから関係ないと思えばそれだけのことですよ
食べる量減らそうと思ったらね
減らすぞと で 適量な１日はこれぐらいの適量だよと決めて
それ以外は関係ありませんと
いうふうなこの心のコントロールが必要なんですよ
これがないとずっとそういう薬に薬
もう化学薬品にもう自分を毒殺するということになるんです
そういうことで まあそれは俗世間の話で
こちらは人格の話で 黙っていうことは
ものは見る 聞く ものは聞く
味わうもの 味わったりもしますが
心の中で嫉妬 憎しみ 怒り
欲 そういうものは生まれないように気をつける
それ生まれないように気をつけるためには
知識的な面白さだけをつけておけば
どんどん頭も良くなります
面白いの面白いんだけど
私に関係ないんだと で
その方法で私はこのゲーム機なんかを調べるんです
ヨドバシのゲームばっかり売ってる建物もありますからね
言ったらもう全部機械やら全部見ますよ
でも自分ではやりません
で 誰か上手な子供でもなんかガチャガチャとこれに夢中になってやっていると
見る あ なかなかいいですねとかね
画像はよろしいし 音もいいとかね
はい 終わりと 私には関係ない
だからどうしても買わないということは決まってるし
そんなのをやったって面白くないと
自分にとってはね ってあるし
しかし これは知識データとしては必要なんです
だから そういうところには行けます
行ったことはないのはパチンコですね
あれは玄関見ると嫌になるんです
あれはやっぱり人間やるべきものじゃないと
もうかなり人間を混乱させるものではないかなと
音もね 電子音ばっかり流してやって
もうすごくこの興奮状態でもない
すっごいいろいろ混乱状態作っちゃって
それでみんなずっとやっちゃうんですね
あれではストレス発散できないとは思いますね
ストレス発散すれば 子供が遊ぶところが一番いいんですよ
小さな子供たちが遊ぶところ
そういうのは子供がいないとね
かっこ悪いんだからね
誰か誰かの子供を借りてでもね
この 100円入れたらちょっと動く置物とかね
そういうところは落ち着くんです
そちらにある音にしたっても
やっぱりまあ子供向きの音だから
何のことなくもうもう可愛いと感じるだけでね
それで優しく明るく生きてみようではないかという気分で
その場所を立つことはできます
これには子供を借りなくちゃいけないんですけどね
だからお母さんたちが商売やればね
子供を貸してあげますよと
はい それでダメ それぐらいの特色があれば
私たちはこの世の中からどんな洪水が来てもしっかりした人格が出来上がるんです
もう一度繰り返す ウッターナ
最初のステップはまず踏まなくちゃいけない
大胆に物事を考えるんじゃない
こんなの私にできるわけじゃないとかね
みんなよく瞑想の やっぱり今も悟れますかと
やっぱりすぐじゃああんた帰ってくださいと
そんな悟れないと思うんだったら
なんで来たんですかね
この矛盾っていうのはもう信じられないんですね
だからしっかりしてないんですよ
脳を使ってないんですね
使ったことない人に脳細胞を使う瞑想なんか教えるわけにはいきませんし
で 悟れますかと聞いたって
私は知ったものじゃないんだから
そんなのは 私が言うのは
この最初のステップだけやってみなさいと
そこはずっと必要なんです
すぐ怠けが出て もう腰が重くなっちゃうんですね
だから何しだっても 料理であろうが洗濯であろうか
何でもやっぱり心が怠けが入って
やめよう やめよう 休もう
休もうという気持ちがいつでもありますから
ずっとやっぱりこのステップだけやります
これだけはやりますというぐらいで
ウッターナということ
それからやることにちゃんと集中しておく
ほんのちょっとの集中だから
ほんの瞬間の集中だから
1秒に 100分の1ぐらいの集中力でしょ
それぐらいはできるでしょうに
それを実践する それからこのサンニャマという混乱しない状態を育てる
そうするとやる気が消えなくなりますね
で 落ち着いていられます
それには見るものはちゃんと見る
聞くものはちゃんと聞く
聞いてはあかん 聞いてはあかんと言って言いながら聞く
バカらしい生き方はやめる
聞きたくないものでも
相手が強引に聞かせようと思っているんだったら聞けばいいでしょうに
別に 聞く でも次に出てくる問題は
そんなのを聞いたり見たりすると
怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら出てきて
心が汚れちゃうとどうにもならなくなっちゃって
また主導権がなくなりますから
やっぱり心で面白さ 知識的な面白さだけ育てて
欲と怒りをなくすようにしておく
それでその人は誰に管理できますかね
ずっと自分で主導権を握っているんだから
だから俗世間から出てくる洪水がいっぱいありますからね
だから落ち込む人間っていうのはなくなるんです
世間の波にさらされて不幸になったとかね
そんなのは仏教の世界ではありえない話なんです
でも誰もやってないんだからね
しょうがないんですけど
お釈迦様はそういう人間というのはとんでもないんだと
世間の波がどうで勝手にしろと
私は高いところで島作ってるんだよと
自分で主導権を取って独立しているんだよという島を作りなさいと
島っていうのは自分の人格のことなんです
これは実現できない難しい話じゃないんです
阿弥陀様にか神様にお祈りして得られるものじゃないんです
自分の手で 自分の心ですぐ現実化できる話なんです
これでちょっと話が長すぎましたね
これ何かストーリーもありますけどね
ストーリー 5つぐらいつなげているんです
これあの 日本語 日本語でも知ってるチューラパンタカパンタカとか何とかという物語ですけど
あの日本語で知って知られている物語とパーリ語でやる物語っていうのは結構違うんです
で ほんの一部だけ取ってきて
このチューラパンタカという人がね
なかなか頭が悪くて あのという話なんですけど
それは精神障害者やらいろんなこと言ってもそんなことはないし
ストーリーすっごく長いんです
だからあんまり言いたくはないんです
で このチューラパンダカの物語を知らない方々にほんのわずかだけ言いますけど
このまあ ある人が出家して悟り開くんですね
マーパンタカというんですね
その人の姪ですね いて
やっぱりその人も出家させるんです
だからおじいさんはあの阿羅漢になってますけど
まあその子供にもやっぱりしっかりと仏教を教えてあげなくちゃいけないということで
いろいろ勉強させるんですね
勉強させたんですけど
なかなかうまくいかない
全くもう勉強できない
で それでおじさんのお坊さんがもう君は頭が悪くてね
たくさん勉強しなくちゃいけないんだと
1人前の比丘になるためには
でも芸一つも暗記できんでしょうと
だから還俗して帰ってくださいと
と言ったところで でもこの若い人はやっぱり修行したいんですね
修行したいんだけど 自分が出家した師匠がね
帰ってくださいと言ったら
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃって
で 考えてるいるんですね
どうせおじいさんだからね
すぐ心変わるでしょうと待っていたんですけど
まあ信者さんが誰か来て
このお坊さんたちに明日のお布施しますからということで招待したんですね
で 大長老だから 長老がそれを招待を受けて
どれぐらいお坊さんたちはいらっしゃいますかと
お坊さんに聞いたんです
食事用意するために で
これぐらいいますよと
数はいったんです ただ
その若い子はまあ聞いたら一人ないんですね
数一つ少ないんです やっぱり自分を数えてないんだと
自分に帰りなさいと言ったんだから
もう明日のお布施にはこの人の名前入ってないんですね
これでショックになっちゃったんですね
やっぱりおじいさんが本気だと
追い出されたんだと 言っても家に帰りたくないし
ご泣きというんですか
号泣しながらもうどこかで座り込んでいるんです
ずいぶん大きく泣きながら
そちらにお釈迦様が行くんですね
言って 君 なんでそんな号泣ですか？と言ったら
私はおじいさんにマハパンテラという師匠のところへ出家しましたけど
私は修行したいんだと
でも師匠に破門されたと
還俗しなさいと言ったんだと
だから家にも帰りたくないし
しかし 出家すること 出家でいることもできないんだと
私はどうすればいいんですかと
言って泣く お釈迦様は何のことなく
君 この仏教っていうのはね
誰の物か知ってるのかと
まあそれはお釈迦様の教えでしょうと
ということは私の教えでしょう
はい その通り お釈迦様の教えですと
それで私は君に帰ろと言ったんですかと
お釈迦様は言ってないんだと
だから帰れと言えるのはお釈迦様ということなんです
でも私は君に帰れと言ってないでしょう
教えは私のものだよと
言った途端 子供の心がすごく喜びましたし
泣きは止めましたし お釈迦様は自分の味方になってるんだと
おじいさんに破門されてもざまあみろという感じなんです
でお釈迦様はこっちおいでと
でお釈迦様はその子供を自分の弟子にね
直接一応みんな仏弟子なんですけど
やっぱり後輩指導する場合は一人一人当てますから
あまりお釈迦様は個人的な指導はしませんでしたけど
でお釈迦様 じゃあ君 私のところに来いと
で 喜んで来たところで綺麗なちょっとした布を一つあげて
これを洗いなさいと 洗うように
このまあ手でこするっていうこととかね
まあそれやってください
こういう風にやってくださいと
それで一言教えたんですね
ラジョーハラナンという一言はね
このこれを何といいますか
洗うという意味ですね
ラジョーっていうのは汚れっていう意味で
汚れを落としますと 汚れたものはあげなかったんですけど
綺麗な服をあげてものをあげたんです
お釈迦様にすごい単純な仕事をさせたんだから
せっかくお釈迦様 これはこうやってあの
あの あの洗濯板の上でこすっちゃうでしょ
そんな感じで手でやってくださいと
お釈迦様に言われたものだから
真剣に文句はないで それはやったんですよ
あの言葉も言いながら
汚れを落とす 汚れを落とすと
汚れを落とす 汚れを落とすと言いながらやったんだけど
かえって無茶汚れちゃったんです
あ 大変だと 汚れを落とすとお釈迦様に言われたんですけど
これひどく汚れちゃったんではないかと
だから言ってることやってることと結果違うんだと
そこでやっぱり何で汚れたんですかと
考えたら自分がやったことで汚れたんですよ
そちらにその人の心理見えてきたんです
人間のインチキ世界ね
人間が全部綺麗にしているんだぞと言ったっても
人間が全部汚くしているんですからね
だからなんという人生ですか
なんという生き方 全てこういう汚い不浄なものでというふうなことが思い浮かんだんですね
それでお釈迦様は物事はその通りだよと
で ちょっと話しただけで
その人は悟り開くんですよ
時間的にはおそらく一晩頑張った可能性はありますけど
そこら辺はちょっとわからないんですけどね
明確にストーリーは難しくて
とにかく午前中はまあお坊さん
その人には正体はないんだからね
お坊さんたちはみんな食事に信者さんの家に行ったんです
行ったところで お釈迦様に最初にご飯を差し上げますから
お釈迦様にご飯を差し上げると
お釈迦様は断ったんです
だったら何でしょうか？と聞いたら
あんた出家者みんなにオフする約束でしたではないか
その通りです お寺にいるお坊さんみんな呼んでますよと
違います まだいるんだよと
ちょっとこれは大変約束が違うんだから
すぐその人を送って お寺に一人お坊さんがいるというお話で連れてきてくださいと
大変だ そのお坊さんにオフはないんだから
行ったらお寺いっぱいお坊さんたちいたんだと
で たら その人はまた驚いちゃって
一人じゃない たくさんいるんだと聞いたら
お釈迦様はいい あのチュッラパンタカっていう人ですけど
その人を呼んでくださいと
言ったら チュッラパンタカってお坊さんいるんでしょ？と言ったら
いるお坊さんみんな私はチュッラパンタカだと呼ぶんですね
また困った みんな同じ名前で困ったと
こういうことになっているんだと
それで大変だと お釈迦さんは大丈夫ですと
とにかくこの最初に名前を言う人を連れてこいと
私はチュッラパンタカ
私ですと初めに言う人がいるんだと
その人を連れてきてくださいと
それでその人は言って
チュッラパンタカお坊さんがどなたでしょうか？と聞いたら
一人が私はチュッラパンタカですけどと言ったんです
それでそのお坊さんを手で捕まって
一緒にお釈迦様が呼ばれているんだから食事に来てくださいと
そしたらあのお坊さん
他のお坊さんたちはみんないなくなっちゃったんです
で それはあのお坊さんの瞑想の力で
自分の形をね あっちこっち現象化してしまったんです
幻想化してしまったんです
だから修行最中だから洗う管理も何もできずにね
まあそれでまあ消えてしまったっていう話で
とにかく悟ったんです
午前中で修行して だからあれほど頭が悪いといっても
うまくいったってことなんです
そこで方法なんですよ
三蔵経は全部勉強してやるぞとかね
これのプロになってやるぞ
そんな将来の計画立ててやってもこれはうまくいかないんだと
今の瞬間の仕事をやれば完璧になりますよという話に
で その例を出してるんですね
だからチュッラパンタカ長老さえも悟りましたよと
偈一つも暗記する能力はなかったんですけど
究極的なレベルにまで達したんだよ
だから人間に究極なレベルに達することは何のことなくできますよ
余計なことを考えないならばね
今更末法の時代だから悟れますか？とかね
その人は悟りませんよ
もともともうむちゃくちゃだから
だから悟るか悟らないどうでもいいでしょ
そんなことは 自分の今の一秒の仕事をすれば
それをやらない人は何も得られないでしょうに
だからこの一秒の仕事をしなさいよと
その一秒のために腰を上げなさいよと
その一秒のことに集中しなさいよ
私は怒りよくきれいさっぱりなくそうと
どうでもいいんだよ そんな話はいい加減な妄想は
今の瞬間で怒れませんよと
明日わかりませんだけど
今の瞬間では欲張らないんだぞと
それ今の瞬間だけで十分ということなんです
それで完璧な人間になります
見てみなさいよと でお釈迦様は例までちゃんとチュッラパンタカさんのエピソードで見せたんです
見てみろと あんた方から見ればまるっきり頭のない人でしょうと
今はどうですかと 今はどんなもんですか
いろいろストーリーありますからね
面白いと思いますけど
時間がないし で 日本語では声紋を訳しているところあるならば読んでみてください
ではあの話はここら辺で終了します
ではダンマパダ講義はこれで終了したいと思います
それから四十分ほど休憩いたしまして
午後五時からヴィパッサナー瞑想実践会の続きやりますので
ぜひそちらの方もご参加ください
では最後に  質問等あるんでしょうかね
質問はもし今この場でどうしても質問したい方いらっしゃいましたらどうぞ
質問したい方々はいろいろ話したい方々は
あ どうぞ  すみません チュッラパンタカの話なんですけども
パーリ語経典と日本で通用している話と少し違うということで
今初めてお伺いしたんですが
全文というか パーリ語経典の日本語訳というものはどこかで入手できますか？ ありますね
ダンマパダ方はそのまま訳した日本語はね
全訳はないと思いますよ
抄訳がいくつかあると思うんですけど
全部訳したものってのは多分刊行はされてない
何卷でもないんですか？ あれは抄訳だと思います
一応北島さんって方がダンマパダの
あれはあんまりよくない
つけたものありますけど
ほんのちょっとですよ
あれぐらいだけちょっとやった
あの人よりはもっとだらしないんです
で テーラワーダじゃなくて
どなたも知ってるんですか？読んだことないんで
ダンマパダの物語 何か本があるような気がしますけど
水野興玄さんという弟子の方で
女性の方が訳してるのは今手本にしたものありますけど
一部だけです  この一人ぐらい
これ最初のところだからもちろんそれとあるかもね
やってる方もいるかもしれませんけど
ぜひトライしていただければ
漢文の訳は全部できましたよね
それはできて 上下で だけどパーリ語の方はじゃないですね
英訳とかですかね  英訳はありますけど
英訳は全部あります 延々といろんなの書いてるんだから
あまり私はストーリー言っちゃうと
時間がいくらあっても足らなくなるんですね
英訳はちゃんとできてますね
質問ございますか  頭で瞬間の集中力を保たなければいけないとか
瞬間の集中 瞬間の集中というよりも長い瞬間の集中
瞬間の集中を保つ  10分
20分  30分  40分  50分って言って
今まで集中力が続いたんですけど
瞬間うん それをどなたでもにも返事できると思います
どなたか返事してください
1秒の瞬間ができれば
次の1秒はできる 次の1秒もまだできる
ということは 20秒間ずっといます
お釈迦様の言葉で最後にパウチヤサンガというその言葉の言葉で
私もそれをちょっと聞きたかったんですけど
その意味とやっぱり考えてたら
やっぱり瞬間瞬間ずっと途絶えることなく続いてるんだなと思ったんですが
だから話は全部元に戻したいんです
そんなのは人間にできるんですか？今から悟りますか？という質問でしょ
そんなこと考えること自体もうアホもいいところだと言っていたんだから
今の自分にできることをやりなさいという話でしょ
あと全部話を振り出しに元に戻したいんでしょうね
そんなことできるかと
そんな考え方は最初から間違ってるんだよと今 2時間半も喋ったんです
ウッターネーマっていう意味ですね
ウッターネーマっていうことはないし
やろうとする気持ちがないっていうことなんですね
だからそのためにそんなできるんですか？と
20時間もサティを入れなさいと言ってるんではないか
できるわけないんだぞとかね
だからやろうという気持ちはないんです
たった 1秒でもサティは入れようとはしないんですね
やろうという気持ちですから
うん そういう  瞬間にその瞬間
いくつかの瞬間ならできるけど
それを持続して最後までしていく
最初のその踏み出すという
ことで だから考え方を改めた方がいいんです
1秒間できれば十分やと
うん それでウッターナという性格はずっと続くんです
1秒できたんだから で
やめたそうと思ったらウッターナがないでしょ
奮起はないでしょ  1秒できたら 1秒できたんだからといって喜べばいいし
はい それで終わりってことじゃないんですよ
富士山を全部平らにするようだったら
一つだけあの土をクワで掘ったら
はい終わり はい 平らになったってことはないでしょうに
クワで一つ土を掘ったならば
またもう一つ掘らなくちゃいけないんです
だから富士山が丸ごと平らにすることできるかということはどうでもいい話で
自分の仕事だけすればいいんです
それにはウッターナという性格はずっと必要なんです
一歩は進むと 進むのはこの一歩だけと
それでいつでもそれで行くんです
進むのはこの一歩だけですと
いっぺんに 10歩を進むんじゃないんだよと
おはようございます はい
あの欲の顔面がというところなんですけども
どうしてもそういう欲とかを自制するって言うんですけど
自制してばかりいて自制するのと我慢するっていうことなんですけど
それだとどうしても余計不満に感じしまうと思うんですが
その余計不満になるとまた欲が湧いちゃってとして
また同じことになっちゃうかなと思う時があるんですが
その解決策として そういうことではなくて
欲しさを認めるというのがあったと思うんですが
その欲求に立ち向かうんじゃないんですか？ 私の話は全部話しました
まだリピートされるような質問ではなくて
反論やら別な意見とかね
言ったら喋りますけど
だから自制するとか なんとか抑えるとかね
そんな話はしてないでしょうに
今きから質問は まあちゃんと考えた上で
私は説法で説明したんです
欲 怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬っていうのは
情けない みっともないんだから
それは生まれないようにしなさいと
生まれない方法っていうのは見るものは見るんだけど
それを面白さを発見すると
どうやって欲求不満になるかっていうことはね
私はわかりませんだけど
面白いんだから 面白さ発見してない人にとっては
あれ食べたいのに 食べたいのに
やっぱり食べてわかんとかね
そんなの精神的な病気でしょうに
食べたいんだったら食いなさいよと
食べてはいけないんだったら
これは美味しいんだけど
私には関係ないんだよと
それだけのことで 別に欲求不満にはなりません
私は厳密に計算して喋ってるんです
で この俗世間のくだらない人々はね
言うことは知ってます
欲なんか抑えてはいけませんとかね
こんなのは精神的に病気になるんだぞとか
欲求不満というのは大変なことやとかね
その話にずっと乗ってるんだったら
この話は全く正反対のことを言うんだから回らないとは思いますし
で 自分の欲望は全部満たすという方法が正しいかと
だったら私は 100人ぐらい殺したくなったら殺すこと正しいでしょうに
10人の女の人と結婚したくなったら
やっぱりこれはあなたの欲求だからね
抑えてはいけませんよという話でしょうに
堂々とそういう屁理屈は世間で言うし
屁理屈だからこそ みんなじっとその話だけ聞く
論理的に言うと なかなか頭に入らないということもあります
まあそれはわかりますけど
私はちゃんと論理的に事実を言ってるんです
欲しいんだからといって
人間それをやっちゃうと病気になるんですよ
怒ったんだからって 自分がそれ行動起こすとそれ自体精神病気なんですよ
人間は精神的に健康的になりたければ
怒り 憎しみ 欲などっていうのはちゃんと捨てなくちゃいけないんです
抑えるとか自制とかっていうのは
ありのままあったまんまで抑えることだから
なんでそれはいいんですかね
毒蛇が家にいるまんまで毒蛇から気をつけると毒蛇を追い出せばいいでしょうに
毒蛇から気をつけることで自分がストレス溜まっちゃってしょうがないんだと
夜も寝られないんだと
自分の部屋に毒蛇がたくさん住んでるんだと
あなたは毒に噛まれたら死ぬと言ってるんだから
私は気をつけているんですけど
寝られないんだと 誰が悪いんです？毒蛇を追い出せばいいんだから
私は言ったら毒蛇を追い出せと
部屋に住ませてはいけないんだと
夜 心理学者いうのはやっぱり抑えてはいけないんだという話でしょうに
だったらヘビに噛まれて死ぬしか方法ないんです
毒蛇がいくらいたっても
あんたはグーグーと寝なさいという話でしょうに
ですから この怒り 欲 憎しみなどっていうのは育ててはいけない
だから抑えてもいけないんです
抑えるもんでも自制するもんでもないんです
心に住まないようにするもんです
追い出すもんです 追い出したものは別に抑えるとか話にならんでしょうに
だから追い出すためには別なものを住んでもらえば
私は言うのはもう蛇食べる鳥がいるでしょ
まあ知らないでしょうね
蛇を平気で捕って食べる鳥たちがいるんですよ
え？あ クジャクも食べるし
まあこのワシ なんとかこの系のもう捕って食べるんですよ
で まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
例えば蛇を食べるあのフクロウがいるんだと
自分がフクロウ飼っちゃえばいいでしょうに
あいつは全部食べちゃいますから
だから 欲 嫉妬 怒り 憎しみの代わりに面白さを入れなさいと
面白さっていうのは暗くないでしょうに
明るいでしょうに だから自制やら抑制やら抑圧とか関係ない話なんです
そんなのはもう心理学者の世界で
だからそういう理屈を理解してほしいんです
聞いてますかね で これは俗世間の話じゃないんです
だから怒りあるまんまで
やっぱり怒ってはあかん
怒ってあかん そんな話にならないんです
怒るんじゃなくて あんた言うこと面白いなとかね
それだけでしょうに まあ具体的な例で言えば
誰か私にむちゃくちゃ文句言って怒っている
それで私は怒らないでよく話を聞く相手の
あ なるほど そういうことですかね
面白いね あんた言うことはね
全然合ってないんだけど
面白いんだよと よくそういう面白いストーリー作ったもんだなとかね
そうやってそこら辺の話を分析して
その中から面白さを発見すると
自分が 1かけらも怒ったことはないし
それで怒らないようにするぞというくだらないやりもないしね
そういうことで あの俗世間のやり方とは全くも違う
これはまるっきりブッダの世界で智慧の世界なんです
それはもう違うということは比べる
比較することはできない
私はもうまるっきりもう俗世間の知識はもう全部否定した時点から喋ってるんです
だからこの あの人こう言ってる
この人こう言ってると言っちゃうと
もうもう時間いくらあっても足りませんだから
日本で人気あるあの心理学者
誰でしたっけ あのユング
カールユングとかね 日本語でユンゲと言うでしょ
ユンゲはこう言った ああ言ったとか
ユング ああ言った こう言ったとかね
私はまとめてあんなのはゴミだと捨ててるんですよ
あれはいかに人を精神的にイカれた状態にするかというためにはいいんですけどね
あっちこっちから本人もすごい精神不安定で
自分が精神的に引かれてて
あっちこっちいろんなものを調べただけの話でしょうに
禅のことも だから日本で人気あるんですけど
全部分かってるんですかと
だからもうそういうこの暗闇で物を触っていう人の話
これはもうまるっきり光を当てて
もう光もう開発したブッダの話だから
これは比較することさえもできん
ユングよりは心の状態はわかりやすくシグムンド・フロイトは分析したんですけどね
ユンゲはもうユングでしたっけ
ユング カール・ユングはあのほとんど神秘家でしょ
心理学者というよりは
私も一回新報社なんかに行ったことで
あの東大のすごく威張ってた教授がいて
その人の本一つも買ってみたんですけど
読めないんですよ くだらなすぎて
お金はもったいないんです
人の病気一つも治すことできなくてね
で こうごちゃごちゃ分析したってもね
だからまあ お釈迦様が言ってる通りやった方がいいんです
楽です 早いんです  こちらに25のところには 4つお釈迦様が書いていただいて
丁寧に説明されているわけなんですけど
最初の 2つがあの行われれば自動的に
3つ目  4つ目っていうのは進むということではないんですか？ それはありえます
それはあります  最初の2つをとにかく意識して実践していけば
心も落ち着いてくるし
そういう  それはその通りです
だからこのアッパマーダだけに仏性質を全てまとめているのはそういうわけなんです
アッパマーダだけ実践すれば
全て実践したことになります
だから自然になるんですよ
人間に 抑制するとかそんな話にもならない
だからやってみなさいと言ってるんです
だからやってみたら たったアッパマーダだけ実践したってもうまくいく
ウッターナと言ったってもアッパマーダは必要なんです
だからこのウッターナとアッパマーダ 2つさえあれば
もう他は考えなくたっていいんです
でも中途半端で生半可でやっちゃうと
やっぱり次の 2つも気をつけなくちゃいけない
しっかりやるんだったら
たったアッパマーダだけでうまくいきます
はい  恐れというか  はい
それは  ああああ 恐れっていうのは
仏教はやっぱり怒りにカテゴライズするんですよ
怒りの一種ですよ 恐れっていうのは
で 瞬間瞬間に気をつける人にとっては
恐れるということは暇がないんです
忙しくて 怖いと思う暇がないんです
で 例で考えてください
家は火事になったと そこで子供がいる
家の中に自分の 恐れる暇がないんですよ
家に飛び込んで子供を連れて逃げようとするんです
で 自分の子供を 例えば小さな子供だったら
もう柱が落ちようか もうそんな余裕暇がない
とにかく飛び込んで子供を助けようとするだけのことで
だから 瞬間でやるべきことをする人にとっては
恐れが入る余地がないんですよ
恐れは怒りなんです で
怒りという大きな枠の中に入れてる一つなんです
で 怒りも欲があるんだから怒りも出てくるし
欲あるんだから恐れも出てくるし
で 余計なことを考えるんだら恐れるんですよ
例えばもうホームに立っている
余計なことを考える この電車が地下鉄だったら空気も出てくるんだ
やっぱりこの空気圧で
もしかすると私を揺れたらどうしようかと
うかつに立っていたら
この空気圧で倒れたらどうしようかと
倒れたらもし線路に落ちちゃうと
ああ もう終わり それで怖くなるでしょう
そんなくだらんこと考えなくていいでしょうに
別に 大体恐れっていうのは
人間は知らず知らずくだらんことを考えてるんです
あの時々いるでしょ？家にいるとすごく不安定で怯えている人々は
誰かが来たらどうしようかとか
誰かが窓を破ったらどうしようかとかね
そういう人々夜寝られないんですよ
で だから余計なことを考えちゃうと恐れが出てきます
それも怒りですね 自分に対して危険が襲ってくるかもしれません
これは嫌ですということなんです
私に危険が迫っている
しかし 私はそれは絶対嫌ですという怒りが恐れなんです
はい